it was me I barkas hey Ned
we really miss all of your adventures
and meds Declassified School Survival
Guide you are an important part of lots
of kids teenage years because middle
school is no joke we've really learned a
lot about surviving junior high from you
cookie and Mose we wonder what you all
are up to these days
are you in most still together it's
cookie a super successful computer
programmer and where things always
perfect on the set of the show
that's Declassified School Survival
Guide was a hit show on Nickelodeon from
2003 to 2007 but like every show there
are plenty of Secrets and things
Nickelodeon doesn't want you to know
keep watching to find out all the
secrets including which star has a
not-so family-friendly reputation why do
you guys hang out your total opposites
the failed spin-off Ned's Declassified
School Survival Guide was a
Nickelodeon's most popular show in the
early 2000s but it was still loved by a
lot of fans the show was definitely over
the top with all of Ned's ventures but a
lot of it felt really familiar to kids
because it dealt with a lot of common
middle school issues Nickelodeon
considered continuing Ned's Declassified
with kids going into high school in fact
they even shot a pilot episode of the
new show devon Werkheiser who played Ned
signed a contract for this new series it
would have been called Ned's
Declassified High School Survival Guide
it's not clear what other characters
would have continued on but many have
committed to other projects Nickelodeon
ultimately decided not to pick up the
spin-off series but we have to admit we
would have loved it we could have seen
Ned and Moe's relationship develop high
school has a lot of challenges like
trying to fit in with new social groups
Ned and the others could have helped a
lot of kids navigate high school coconut
heads unfinished business
coconut hat is one of the most memorable
Nickelodeon characters ever played by
Rob Kingston coconut head was a nerdy
dramatic kid with really peculiar hair
he was always getting into various
shenanigans on the show his hair looked
a lot like he was wearing a coconut
shell which is why he was called that in
fact did you know that coconut head
didn't have a real name on the show
certain fan sites claimed he did but the
actor says he was always just coconut
head there was originally supposed to be
a surprise storyline for his character
at the end
the show or in a spin-off movie he was
supposed to get a new cool haircut he
was going to come back to school and
become super popular it never happened
and Rob is glad it didn't he likes
playing a character that lets kids know
it's okay to be different as long as
you're being yourself it would have been
a funny sight to see him with new hair
though
Missy not so Meany Missy meanie was
played by Carly KC Missy was a super
popular cheerleader on Ned's
Declassified but she is not nice at all
she is a total mean girl who lives up to
her name she lies and teeth she'll do
anything to get her way I am NOT okay
for part of the show she has a huge
crush on Ned it's obsessive and awkward
but she ends up with crony in the finale
she also starts a club that is a ripoff
of Ned's guidebook the club is full of
terrible ways to survive school but
Carly Casey is nothing like that in fact
she is still great friends with Devon
Werkheiser he's also really good friends
with Carly's boyfriend they worked on
Cherokee together and went to Nepal to
build a school Carly also appeared in
one of Devon's music videos it's hard to
separate characters from the actors when
we love a show so much but we were
really glad to know that Carly is
nothing like Missy meaning where they
are now it's easy for fans of Ned's to
classify to imagine all the characters
growing up and having fun
awesome lives but the actors who play
them are very different people some of
the actors from the show have continued
acting but other's lives took a totally
different turn remember Lisa's emo she
was a girl who quicky hated at first but
eventually had a crush on she was played
by Rachel cinder and Rachel hasn't done
any acting since the show ended she was
in one short film that same year that
Ned's Declassified went off the air no
one really knows what she's up to these
days besides doing some charity work
Evelyn Quang was played by Michelle Kim
she also didn't continue acting and is
now a photojournalist the saddest story
about one of the show's actors is mr.
right
miss Ike Taylor was a successful and
talented actor he even won an Emmy but
he sadly passed away in 2014 very
content in October 2019
at the Michigan daily newspaper wrote an
investigative article about meds to
classify she was a fan of the show and
she went looking to stream it but the
show is nearly impossible to find
line without pain by episode a few years
ago it was available on Netflix for a
short amount of time but now it's only
on Amazon and you have to pay for each
episode or season the journalist Ali
Owens wanted to know why other
Nickelodeon shows from that time are
easy to find and watch
she thinks that Nickelodeon is trying to
bury the show Big Time Rush from the
same creators wasn't nearly as popular
as Ned's Declassified but it's on Hulu
here's the thing about Ned's
Declassified though it wasn't all that
popular compared to other shows it
didn't get a lot of Kids Choice Awards
and some of the storylines might be
problematic in today's world but the
show still had a lot of wholesome
content and she thinks kids could use a
show like Ned's Declassified these days
do you love nostalgic content well so do
we
we post videos about old Disney Channel
and Nickelodeon TV shows and movies
subscribe to the things for more awesome
throwback videos if you're watching on
your phone or tablet make sure you have
your notifications enabled in settings
then you'll never miss another video
real-life love story on nights
Declassified School Survival Guide we
saw Ned deal with a lot of issues and
like a lot of teenagers he had problems
with his love life he's been most of the
show pining over Susie crabgrass and
they even dated for a while but fans
always shipped him with his BFF Mose in
the last episode he had to choose
between Mose and Susie's everyone was so
glad you picked Mose but here's
something you might not know they dated
in real life to Devon work either and
Lindsay Shaw got super close while they
were filming the series stay dated each
other for about a year after the show
wrapped up devon has said that Lindsay
was his first love isn't that the cutest
thing ever
they may not be together anymore but
they are still good friends they talked
a few times a year and still grab lunch
to catch up Devon says he makes a point
to hang out with Lindsay at least once a
year we love that they are still such
great friends keep watching to find out
what has really happened to Suzy
crabgrass wig secrets coconut heads hair
had a lot of Secrets
and some of them are really surprising
his hair was always such a funny part of
the show the show's producers asked Rob
Kingston to shave his head for the role
so he could wear a wig he was happy to
shave his head he had a bull cut at the
time and was glad to get rid of it also
his hair was
supposed to look like that at all it was
originally supposed to be really spiky
we can't imagine coconut head with
different hair Rob said the wig fell off
all the time when they were filming and
there were two wigs he had a special wig
for stunts so the regular one wouldn't
get messed up Rob was quite the jokester
on set he used to pretend to have a
conversation with a tiny man in his wig
it became a running joke and the other
cast members would talk to his wig to
that wig was an important part of Rob's
childhood he wasn't supposed to but he
stole the wig when the show ended he
still has it
wilderness man one of the stars have
meant Declassified has gone well wild
but we weren't talking about partying or
illegal activity we're talking about
becoming a total wilderness man do you
remember Billy Loomer he was a big bully
of the show he led a trio of bullies at
school Loomer was played by Kyle Swan
who is a total opposite of a bully he
and Devon have been good friends ever
since the show like some of the other
actors Kyle quit acting after the show
concluded he went to college to study
marine biology he's apparently super
smart then he moved to New Zealand he
goes scuba diving with sharks he does
underwater photography and shoot
underwater nature documentaries and he
totally looks the part look at that
awesome wild beard he and Devin still
see each other whenever Kyle comes back
to the States to visit that is
definitely something we never would have
expected of Billy Loomer Ned's guide to
your 20s the cast of Ned's Declassified
School Survival Guide is all grown up
these days they are learning how to
navigate adulthood and let's be honest
learning to be an adult is hard work
recently and Devon Werkheiser tweeted to
ask if anyone would be interested in a
Ned's Declassified revival he said he
could use a guide on how to balance life
as a twenty-something year old fans were
totally behind the idea Devon said he
would see what he could do now there is
no confirmation that a revival is
happening but Netflix and Nickelodeon
have recently merged to create a bunch
of new shows based on some of their
older nostalgic content and we are here
for it
we know Disney Plus is doing something
similar with Lizzie McGuire we would
love to see Nickelodeon give us an
update on Ned Mo's cookie and
coconut head it would be awesome Devin
definitely seems down for it we wonder
if that tweet is a sneaky way to see if
fans would watch a reboot Suzy's r-rated
future Susie crabgrass is one of Moses
best friends and Ned's love interest for
most of the show surprise
she was played by Christian Cerritos
Christian is probably the most
successful actress from Ned's
Declassified and thankfully the cast of
the show has avoided the scandals there
are a lot of former child stars ha but
Christian has definitely gotten rid of
her Nickelodeon wholesome image she is
known for playing Rosita Espinosa in the
walking dead that show couldn't be
further from what Ned's Declassified was
vide in 2015 Christian really got rid of
the family friendly vibe she posed for a
famous adult magazine she was in the
after-hour section of the magazine while
she didn't bear it all if you know what
we mean her poses were definitely
suggestive Christian became a series
regular on the walking dead after fans
fell in love with her character she's
also going to play selena quintanilla in
an upcoming series about the late singer
we think it's awesome that Suzie
crabgrass has grown up to be so
successful what's your favorite dense
Declassified Survival Guide moment let
us know in the comments section thanks
for tuning in hit that like button if
you are a Ned's Declassified fan see you
next time